hi i'm jenny and today i'd like to talk
to you about a question that comes up
from enterprises quite a bit
how do you choose when and where to use
service management
and when and where to use api management
while it may feel like there's overlap
i'm here to highlight the differences
that make it easy to pick the right
technology for your use cases
[Music]
first we'll do a quick overview on
service management and api management
and then we're going to jump into the
modernization journey as well as some
use cases
we'll summarize everything at the end
but for now let's dive right in
first let's cover the basics what are
service management and api management
service management is usually done with
a service mesh
it manages the communications between
services and it's focused on handling
overall service to service policies or
telemetry
api management is usually done with an
api platform
it's all about managing the life cycle
of apis and is geared towards api
publishing
consumption governance and receiving
analytics of usage of apis by consumers
those sound pretty different so what's
the confusion about
here's the thing both service management
and api management are an essential part
of an enterprises modernization journey
so the real question is not which one to
choose
rather when and where you might choose
one over the other depending on where
you are in your modernization journey
or you might choose api management for
one use case
and service management for a different
part of your business with a different
use case
if you're involved in a modernization
journey then you most likely have one or
both of the following goals
to modernize applications with cloud
native technologies to deliver software
faster
or transform businesses by giving
developers partners and customers unique
ways to interact with your products
to accomplish both of these goals you'll
need both the service management and api
management
let's walk through six scenarios where
you can decide where and when to choose
service management
and or api management first up
imagine your organization is building an
internal platform with requirements
around standardized security
policies and controls here a service
management layer will give you all the
capabilities you need to secure and
control the traffic within that platform
next your sre team wants to monitor the
health and performance of the services
within that platform
in this scenario service management can
provide your team with the metrics
logs and tracing so they can set slos
and get alerts
and what about when a network operator
on your team needs to configure
networking components so that services
can communicate across clusters
in hybrid and or multi-cloud situations
service management provides you a way to
standardize networking across those
environments and components
and now imagine that this platform is
owned by a business unit within an
enterprise
they might want to set up a shared
service model where other business units
can discover
and reuse some of those standardized
services as apis
in this case the goal is to provide easy
visibility for other teams
which are outside the domain of trust
into what apis are available and how to
use them
an api management platform is a great
way to govern this process
it would provide the mechanism to expose
these apis to other teams
provide access to these services and the
tools to measure api usage
through analytics here this organization
is now at a point where they want to
bring
third party partners and developers into
the mix
this could be to adhere to industry
practices such as open banking
or to expand your business model to new
channels
similar to our last use case an api
management platform will let you
securely expose those services outside
of your organization and give you the
tools and provide easy onboarding and
access
now that you've given all these
stakeholders access to those apis
you want to see how they're being used
and potentially even explore some
monetization opportunities
this is another scenario where an api
management platform is a great fit
you can get visibility into api
consumption and growth
determine which apis are valuable and
put monetization models around apis that
you want to charge third parties for
as you can see there are many distinct
use cases for service management and api
management
depending on your needs you may start
with one or the other
you may use them for different
initiatives or you may even use both
service management and
api management together to perform
different functions for a platform that
you're building
to summarize if you're primarily looking
for a technology for service to service
communication
that maintains the quality of service in
a system composed of distributed
services
then service management is the best fit
and if you're looking to drive
consumption of those services
as apis by different business units or
partners
and build new business channels then api
management
is the best fit in our experience both
service management
and api management are crucial in any
organization's application modernization
journey
here at google we provide service
management capabilities through antho
service mesh
which is a part of anthos and api
management capabilities through apogee
check out these links below for more
information and let us know what else
you'd like to learn about google cloud
[Music]
you